[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight's the end of impeachment
week one the public hearings began this
week in Washington Democrats kicked off
the spectacle on Wednesday you'll
remember by trotting on a procession of
State Department functionaries each
explained how deeply upsetting it has
been to watch an elected president
control America's foreign policy they
hate that interestingly though none of
them said they'd seen the president
commit any sort of actual wrongdoing and
was much the same story today the star
witness was the former ambassador to
Ukraine Murray Ivanovich who was
dismissed from her job earlier this year
by the president now keep in mind that
Yvonne Yvette's was testifying at an
impeachment hearing so the only question
on the table was and remains has Donald
Trump committed crimes that would
justify his removal as president of the
United States and fairly early on
Jovanovic stated unequivocally that as
far as she knows he has not do you have
any information regarding the president
United States accepting any bribes no do
you have any information regarding any
criminal activity that the President of
the United States has been involved with
at all no well there you have it no I
have no evidence of any kind that the
president was involved in criminal
activity that was her answer and it
should have been the last thing that she
said today everything after that was a
waste of our time in a country with so
many problems that time-wasting is a sin
and yet Murray Ivanovich kept going and
going and going by the end the hearing
sounded like a therapy session or an
extended meeting with the HR department
the definition of Hell Donald Trump's
real offense turned out to be wounding
the beautiful soul of a highly sensitive
former American ambassador so just like
that you had to leave Ukraine as soon as
possible yes how did that make you feel
terrible honestly I mean after 33 years
of service to our country
it was terrible how did that make you
feel that's a real question how do they
make you feel if you had to choose a
color to represent your emotional state
right now what color would it be it went
on like this for
c---span meets the shrinks office
without upsetting you too much I'd like
to show you the excerpts from the call
and the first one where President Trump
says the former ambassador from the
United States
the woman was bad news and the people
she was dealing with in the Ukraine were
bad news so I just want to let you know
what was your reaction when you heard
the President of the United States refer
to you as bad news I couldn't believe it
I mean again shocked appalled devastated
that the President of the United States
would talk about any ambassador like
that to a foreign head of state and it
was me
I mean I couldn't believe it yeah
without upsetting you too much
I was shocked appalled devastated
criticized I couldn't believe it
now keep in mind this is the person we
hired to represent our country's
interest before a foreign government in
one of the roughest regions in the world
shocked appalled it's pretty
embarrassing in fact it's kind of scary
who's doing the screening over there at
the State Department how many other
neurotics currently hold ambassador rank
before anyone could ask that obvious and
in fact vital question Adam Schiff
jumped in to rattle the witness still
more as we sit here testifying the
president is attacking you on Twitter
and I'd like to give you a chance to
respond I'll read part of one of his
tweets everywhere murray ivanovitch went
turned bad she started off in somalia
how did that go and now the president
real time is attacking you what effect
do you think that has on other witnesses
willingness to come forward and expose
wrongdoing well it's very intimidating I
want to let you know ambassador that
some of us here take witness
intimidation very very seriously it's
very intimidating
it's witness intimidation it's right
witness intimidation that's apparently
what it's called now when someone
criticizes your job performance in
tweet the Gaul it's just terrifying you
know in the same country someone might
step in maybe from the media even to
identify this for what it is a grotesque
joke but Washington is no longer sane so
instead MSNBC spent all day praising
Ivanovich as a holy victim of Trump's
terror this is a witness who is there
not just as a fact witness as the
witnesses on Tuesday but as a victim if
you really walk in her shoes the country
she's gone to the loneliness Jovanovic
is such a soft speaker it really demands
the attention of all these lawmakers
they're working against this straight
are a woman I shouldn't call one cos
that's the president's language this
State Department hero the State
Department historically over the last
thirty years has not exactly been where
you go to find all the powerful women in
Washington usually it was a lot of men a
lot of white men I'm so proud of her and
every woman in America who is fought in
a male-dominated career should cheer for
this woman today I can get choked up
when I think about what this woman has
given Wow did you hear that America the
State Department is quote a lot of men a
lot of white men and that's the worst
kind of men according to accredited
[ __ ] and former senator now open racist
Claire McCaskill ambassy Ivanovich
there's nothing like those horrible
white men MSNBC would like you to know
in fact she lives at the very opposite
end of the moral spectrum among the
sainted somewhere between Gandhi and
your average teenage Swedish climate
activists right in there that sweet spot
of goodness Jovanovic is the sort of
person in fact and they told us this on
CNN that it is quote a gift to know
remarkably poised remarkably credible
Democrats may regret not putting her in
the witness chair first
this woman has ice in her veins she's
got a spine of Steel she laid out I
thought in brilliant detail who she was
this was I thought remarkable testimony
she's incredibly charismatic Wow was she
a powerful witness about I'm an American
dream I was appointed by Ronald Reagan I
have done this for years I'm trying to
fight the bad guy
I covered the weather stirred in a Bill
Clinton presidency in the George W Bush
presidency one of the gifts of the job
is when you meet these people when you
travel the world you know in this age of
Trump I am genuinely shocked by his
behavior with regard to this foreign
service officer of three decades to
disparage her to demean her in sexist
overtones saying the woman over there
she made a mockery of his dismissals of
the deep state if this is the deep state
I bet a lot of Americans looked up and
said yeah I'll take more of that oh yeah
yeah that's right Americans the deep
they can't get enough
let's vest even more power in the hands
of shadowy retired Intel officials who
live for a living and whose agendas can
never be fully known if you spent enough
time in Walmart or Denny's you actually
hear people say that out loud
Americans are sick of this democracy
thing and yet at the same time as CNN
points out Americans also despise sexism
which if you want a precise definition
means any criticism of a woman who is
currently serving the interests of the
Democratic Party so attacking for
example Kellyanne Conway that's not
sexism which is why they were able to do
it yesterday on CNN but criticizing
ambassador Jovanovic for her work
product that is sexism got it okay on to
lesson number two that we learned today
what Donald Trump has done in Ukraine is
bribery now how exactly is it bribery
don't ask dumb questions it just is it's
bribery listen to the geniuses explain
it seems to me that the president the
United States either committed extortion
and bribery of a foreign official or
attempted extortion and bribery of a
foreign official the devastating
testimony corroborated evidence of
bribery she's right to use that word it
is bribery there any number of
potentially impeachable offenses
including bribery the american people
will hear evidence of bribery extortion
the president using his office for
personal gain and this is a very strong
case of bribery let's like the primates
got a new word primary there's a very
strong case for bribery actually there's
no case for bribery and that's why they
only started using the word bribery this
week after running the whole thing for
the folk
group and finding out that bribery was
the scariest possible description of
something they won't actually define but
whatever the specifics don't matter none
of this matters you know exactly what
happen everyone knows and they do two
Democrats decided on the punishment
three years ago impeachment and they've
been looking for the crime ever since